Hello. My name is Birke Baehr,
and I'm 11 years old.
I came here today to talk about what's wrong with our food system.
First of all, I would like to say
that I'm really amazed at how easily kids are led to believe
all the marketing and advertising
on TV, at public schools
and pretty much everywhere else you look.
It seems to me like corporations
are always trying to get kids, like me,
to get their parents to buy stuff
that really isn't good for us or the planet.
Little kids, especially,
are attracted by colorful packaging
and plastic toys.
I must admit, I used to be one of them.
I also used to think that all of our food
came from these happy, little farms
where pigs rolled in mud and cows grazed on grass all day.
What I discovered was this is not true.
I began to look into this stuff
on the Internet, in books and in documentary films,
in my travels with my family.
I discovered the dark side of the industrialized food system.
First, there's genetically engineered seeds and organisms.
That is when a seed is manipulated in a laboratory
to do something not intended by nature --
like taking the DNA of a fish
and putting it into the DNA of a tomato. Yuck.
Don't get me wrong, I like fish and tomatoes,
but this is just creepy.
(Laughter)
The seeds are then planted, then grown.
The food they produce have been proven
to cause cancer and other problems in lab animals,
and people have been eating food produced this way
since the 1990s.
And most folks don't even know they exist.
Did you know rats that ate genetically engineered corn
had developed signs of liver and kidney toxicity?
These include kidney inflammation and lesions and increased kidney weight.
Yet almost all the corn we eat
has been altered genetically in some way.
And let me tell you,
corn is in everything.
And don't even get me started on the Confined Animal Feeding Operations
called CAFOS.
(Laughter)
Conventional farmers use chemical fertilizers
made from fossil fuels
that they mix with the dirt to make plants grow.
They do this because they've stripped the soil from all nutrients
from growing the same crop over and over again.
Next, more harmful chemicals are sprayed on fruits and vegetables,
like pesticides and herbicides,
to kill weeds and bugs.
When it rains, these chemicals seep into the ground,
or run off into our waterways,
poisoning our water too.
Then they irradiate our food, trying to make it last longer,
so it can travel thousands of miles
from where it's grown to the supermarkets.
So I ask myself,
how can I change? How can I change these things?
This is what I found out.
I discovered that there's a movement for a better way.
Now a while back,
I wanted to be an NFL football player.
I decided that I'd rather be an organic farmer instead.
(Applause)
Thank you.
And that way I can have a greater impact on the world.
This man, Joel Salatin, they call him a lunatic farmer
because he grows against the system.
Since I'm home-schooled,
I went to go hear him speak one day.
This man, this "lunatic farmer,"
doesn't use any pesticides, herbicides,
or genetically modified seeds.
And so for that, he's called crazy by the system.
I want you to know that we can all make a difference
by making different choices,
by buying our food directly from local farmers,
or our neighbors who we know in real life.
Some people say organic or local food is more expensive,
but is it really?
With all these things I've been learning about the food system,
it seems to me that we can either pay the farmer,
or we can pay the hospital.
(Applause)
Now I know definitely which one I would choose.
I want you to know that there are farms out there --
like Bill Keener in Sequatchie Cove Farm in Tennessee --
whose cows do eat grass
and whose pigs do roll in the mud, just like I thought.
Sometimes I go to Bill's farm and volunteer,
so I can see up close and personal
where the meat I eat comes from.
I want you to know that I believe
kids will eat fresh vegetables and good food
if they know more about it and where it really comes from.
I want you to know that there are farmers' markets
in every community popping up.
I want you to know that me, my brother and sister
actually like eating baked kale chips.
I try to share this everywhere I go.
Not too long ago,
my uncle said that he offered my six-year-old cousin cereal.
He asked him if he wanted organic Toasted O's
or the sugarcoated flakes --
you know, the one with the big striped cartoon character on the front.
My little cousin told his dad
that he would rather have the organic Toasted O's cereal
because Birke said he shouldn't eat sparkly cereal.
And that, my friends, is how we can make a difference
one kid at a time.
So next time you're at the grocery store, think local,
choose organic, know your farmer and know your food.
Thank you.
(Applause)